les étangs de bonnel classée réserve
naturelle régionale c'est la décision
votée le 13 octobre dernier par le
conseil régional couronnant plusieurs
années de travail entre la commune et le
parc naturel de la vallée de chevreuse
je suis content parce que c'est une
reconnaissance du travail qui a été fait
pendant ces vingt dernières années
l'espace des ventes bonne elle est un
espace que nous avions souhaité classé
depuis les années 90 1990 en réserve
naturelle volontaire le statut n'existe
en plus il ya une vraie reconnaissance
de la part de la région poules d'eau
canards chevreuil ou sanglier ce site
regorge d'une faune et d'une flore
importante avec notamment 94 espèces
d'oiseaux et 36 espèces de libellules un
patrimoine naturel mélangé à un
patrimoine historique le tout s'étendant
sur 22 hectares la duchesse d'uzès avait
fait de cet étang de cet étang principal
de la réserve naturelle un lieu de
balade avec il y avait un embarcadère
pour aller faire de la barre que vont
tous à l'embarcadère existe toujours
mais maintenant c'est plutôt un
observateur pour oiseaux le temple
d'amour qui est un magnifique petit pont
avec des constructions dessus qui est
superbe tout ça nous l'avons réhabiliter
jusqu alors nous étions toujours aidé
par le parc naturel régional à la fois
par la région et le département des
yvelines et les taux de subvention va
être sensiblement les mêmes ça ne
changera rien sinon ce n'est que le
comité de scientifiques saura plus ce
régional que départemental
observations relevées et suivis
scientifiques permettront aux experts de
préserver la faune et la flore de cette
nouvelle réserve naturelle